I feel like we're helping the nation out
with this relationship advice yeah
somebody called me other than said that
they enjoyed it
our first one is from Angelo from San
Diego Angelo Angelo or Angela Angelo
with the show I don't know anymore I
don't know anymore yeah what are we
gonna get at your show what's up Brandon
what's up the whole lot of gang [ __ ]
buzz buzz gang bro I'm coming to you
guys for some dating advice I'm 23 years
old and I consider myself to be you know
in decent shape I mean I work out five
six days a week
I trained that muy Thai that one
two-hitter getting active got a job in
school but I just can't seem to find the
one every girl that's interested either
has a boyfriend
most the time or I don't know if they're
lying to me or what but yeah so do I
just start pulling up on girls in the
gym that are squatting and asking for a
spot or do I try to help her on that
deadlift form you know what I'm saying
like how do I go about this doing this
it's hard out here in the streets for
for a 23 year old and I don't think it
should be that hard I mean I see some
ugly dudes pull some dye me die mm-hmm
yeah that's for sure [ __ ] I'm at least
a hard seven bro and I can't even I
can't even find my buddy so okay I don't
know what to do hopefully you guys can
help me out there whole lot of gang [ __ ]
gang Bruce Buzzz Buzzz good luck it you
think I could be on cocaine cuz the
curtains are really drawing close
together and swords hanging behind him
on the wall as well if you noticed that
and that's enough both of those are
signs of cocaine he's got a cat here cat
what do you think's going on with this
young man I don't know what's going on
but absolutely do not come to a girl
while she's squatting her deadlifting
that's so annoying it's a bad idea
yeah cuz she means business if she's
squatting exactly I say go up to her
compliment her on like how strong she is
and then just walk away damn girls that
315 pounds have a good night
oh yeah I'm more inclined to pay
attention to guys who give me a nice
compliment and just go about their day
then guys who try to linger I'm like oh
you don't linger and then they give you
advice and
what if he asked her a you want split a
protein smoothie after this I don't know
where your mouth has been no wow he's
not gonna baby bird it to him he's not
gonna he's gonna get your own straw yeah
one cup two straws baby yeah I mean I
think this guy obviously you know could
have been doing some cocaine I think
because they got the curtains drawn the
swords and look I've been there brother
you know I got swords at home you know
and I got thick curtains brother so I've
seen that going on and uh and I think
you you seem like a god it's staying in
shape you could probably find a decent
lady you're only 23 man post some pics
on this screen with your shirt off at
the beach bro they're in come crawling
to you what if you're looking for a real
wife I also think you could consider an
import he's 23 you don't need to order a
Russian bride he 23 just get on them
them apps the kids do D em some dicks he
got this bro I just don't think he's
being active enough spent too much got
in time in the gym and playing [ __ ]
swords yeah and look I like swords man I
think it's probably one of the best
weapons you could use if you know guns
went out of business or whatever what do
you think D what would you do with them
stop don't call yourself a seven you
know relax on yourself numbers he said a
hard seven well what do you give them
Cal what's a girl give up and then we'll
go around the guys his cats tight me she
wouldn't she likes Asians
I like nerdy guys he might be nerdy
xenon knives and yeah maybe I mean he
spends he might be spend too much time
in the gym what do you give him cat one
to ten for my body diced he's Bob fun
you know I'm gonna give him a five oh he
seems like a very nice guy but for my
type I like nerdy guys yeah if I can't
beat your ass I probably am not
attracted to you wow you're like a
praying mantis yeah where they have sex
with the males and rip their heads off
yeah D Big D what do you think about the
505 I don't like the personality he
seems nice it's already like bro you
think you're hot get out of here
seven psych I'm here
sevens like camp counselor sounds like
we're get the gap cute hot you know I'm
cool with this happen and he's bodied up
seems like a nice feller fan of the show
I give him an a brother body a you're
Nate dude go get a lifeguard job be a
[ __ ] lifeguard I'll be a blood donor
if you got a healthy blowing man you got
to get out there and give blood dude a
lot of these guys you know they got good
blood and they're here [ __ ] around
you know and uh if you got nine or
however many pints you have in you 11
what is it 12 well yeah I mean if you
could give at least one you can do one
stop sign off somewhere if you're
healthy like that you know I can't
donate blood though you know cuz I used
steroids when I was young and they say
you can't go got against you yeah
you can't donate blood so I'll still
donate a little and sometimes not tell
them cuz I know I'm good but but also
someone might need that testosterone in
their body that's what I'm saying bro
Jack I never heard anybody drop a
[ __ ] half ounce of this into some of
these twinks brother give them a couple
extra hours out there on the catwalk
that's all I'm trying to say power
bottoms but look man a hard seven dude I
think it's some honesty at least the
guys not giving himself at eight or a
nine but you got to get outdoors man you
got to take your sword outdoors yeah
okay doors so open the Curtis yep it up
live action role play there you go get
that lar boy get that LARP slam them DMS
good luck my man I'll give you a hard
sell LARP lizards bro lot of LARP
lizards
back off my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching